vous m'entendez
avec voilà une phrase bonjour hélène
bonjour peut l'être un petit doute aux
autres votre micro est ce qu'on peut me
dire si on entend bien hélène un look
tout va bien tout va bien parfait donc
hélène à la une de la presse l'accord
trouvé cette nuit entre les membres de
l'union européenne pour réduire les
importations de pétrole russe d'ici la
fin de l'année on en parlait à l'instant
avec damien coquet lieu finalise
l'accord pour un embargo partiel sur le
pétrole russe le quotidien espagnol el
país précise en effet que ce compromis
prévoit une exemption temporaire pour le
pétrole acheminé par oléoduc pour éviter
le veto de la hongrie cet accord a
minima est loin de l'interdiction totale
demandée par la présidente de la
commission européenne pour cela von der
leyen mais les vingt-sept sauvent leur
unité face à la guerre en ukraine c'est
lui le quotidien les mains dans le baril
côté russe le quotidien kommersant
ironisait encore hier soir à l'heure de
mettre sous presse sur les difficultés
des européens à se mettre d'accord
notamment à cause de ce cette position
de la hongrie le journal évoque
également l'embarras delieux face au
risque d'une hausse du prix du pétrole
en raison de cet embargo une hausse qui
pourrait entraîner une augmentation des
revenus pétroliers de la russie
l'embargo s'avérant donc
contre-productif à l'arrivée on croire
aujourd'hui est donc avec cet accord au
bout de la nuit la russie hélène qui
resserre son étau dans le combat soins à
nos confrères un journaliste français a
été tué hier après midi il avait 32 ans
mais le visage de frédéric leclerc imhof
ce journaliste qui racontait la guerre
fait la une notamment ce matin du
quotidien italien la stampa le journal
rapporte que le reporter de 32 ans le 8e
journalistes morts depuis le début du
conflit corps est un convoi d'évacuation
de civils lorsque son véhicule a été la
cible d'un tir russe selon les autorités
ukrainiennes les médias russes citées
eux parlent cinton poste présente
frédéric leclerc imhoff comme à
mercenaires engagés dans la livraison de
munitions aux forces armées ukrainiennes
je cite le parquet national anti
terroristes français vous l'avez dit a
annoncé l'ouverture d'une enquête pour
crimes de guerre frédéric leclerc imhof
faut qu'elle le président ukrainien a
rendu hommage dans une vidéo à diffuser
hier soir le quotidien suisse le temps
s'était intéressée justement à la façon
dont volodymyr zelensky communique
depuis le début du conflit sur la façon
dont il a fait de ses interventions
vidéo une arme diplomatique
le journal fait état au total de près de
50 interventions taillé sur mesure en
fonction de ses interlocuteurs des
parlements étrangers des institutions
internationales mais également des
événements culturels comme le festival
de cannes où les grammy awards le
principal danger de cette stratégie
serait toutefois est d'aboutir à une
dissolution du message selon la
chercheuse nathalie goran qui souligne
les grands écarts rhétorique du
président ukrainien comme lorsqu'il
utilise le terme de génocide alors qu'il
n'existe aucun élément à ce stade
permettant de le justifier si le
discours anti russe de vladimir zelensky
trouve un large écho en occident son
impact reste par ailleurs très limité
dans le reste du monde comme ça on a
détesté ce sondage relayé par deux
gardiennes qui montre que les opinions
négatives sur la russie de poutine reste
largement confinée à l'europe et aux
autres démocraties libérales avec une
majorité dans les pays d'asie opposé à
la rupture des liens économiques avec
moscou et une opinion très partagés sur
ce sujet en amérique latine
l'amérique latine et plus précisément la
colombie hélène ou un ex guérillero est
un milliardaire se sont qualifiés
c'était dimanche pour le second tour de
la présidentielle qui aura lieu dans
trois semaines à l'affrontement entre
gustavo petro le candidat de gauche
ayant des liens avec cuba et rodolphe
rolland hernandez un populiste excentré
que lors de ce second tour laisse
sceptique le wall street journal sans
surprise pauline le quotidien
conservateur américain regarde avec
inquiétude ce pays de 51 millions
d'habitants pencher vers le populisme de
gauche qui attend nuit
aux nations latine je cite les
colombiens vont devoir choisir entre le
diable je cite toujours et l'inconnu
mais les liens entre les liens de
monsieur petro avec cuba et la gauche
latino américaine font de lui le choix
le plus risqué assène le journal dont
l'analyse diffère sensiblement de celle
qu'on a trouvé du côté d'el país sip et
roland portes le 19 juin la colombie
rejoindra le mouvement qui rassemble la
deuxième génération de progressistes
latino américains en quête d'une
identité renouveler mais si hernandez
gagne le populiste de droite donc alors
le pays entrera dans un populisme
incertain écrit le quotidien de centre
gauche espagnol
réponse donc le 19 juin prochain on ne
se quittent pas là dessus elle parce que
je sens que vous avez besoin de bonnes
nouvelles oui j'ai peur je tenais à
partager avec vous ces infos tout
d'abord sachez que mona lisa va bien
malgré la tentative d'entartage dont
elle a été victime dimanche ça c'est la
première bonne nouvelle fait la deuxième
c'est que boire du café permettrait
toujours à la une du times un de vivre
plus longtemps et ça nous autres matinée
livre c'est bien que le café c'est le
nerf de la guerre
nous vivons donc plus vieux mais c'est
pas tout à fait sûr évidemment et qui
sait peut-être peut-être serons-nous
suffisamment en forme pour éviter cette
suédoise de 103 ans pauline qui vient de
battre le record du monde de la personne
la plus âgée a réalisé un saut en
parachute en tandem 103 ans vous m'avez
bien entendu je vous imagine
parfaitement dans quelques années une
tasse de café à la main bien sûr bien
sûr merci beaucoup et l'anem langue vit
à vous